What’s the best way to get my email read?
How should I send files?
You may have many questions about email conduct
- and we’re here to answer them.
A clear subject line can be the difference
between your email being read and being ignored.
Professionals are busy people! Subject lines should be clear, short
and summarise the important part of your message.
For example, if you're emailing your manager
to request a holiday,
your subject line could be something like
‘holiday request: 10 - 14 August.’
Precise information like project titles, meeting
locations, or your email purpose
all make good subject lines.
Never leave it blank, as it can look careless
and gives the reader no idea what your message
is about.
In addition to using the subject line, you
can also show that an email is important by
marking it as urgent or high priority.
Not all email programmes have this function,
however.
Marking an email as urgent will probably get
it read quicker, but only do so when it is
actually urgent.
For example, a happy birthday email to a co-worker
probably doesn’t require immediate attention,
even if you really love birthdays.
Emails are a great way to send and receive files.
However, you should be careful about sending
large files as attachments, or lots of attachments
in one email.
Big attachments can fill up the reader’s
email inbox and cause problems for them.
If you need to send a big file to someone,
then it is a good idea to send them a download
link rather than include it as an attachment.
You can also use other programmes to resize
or compress files to make them small enough
to send by email.
Subscribe to our channel for more videos on
how to improve your English language skills.